it looks like lost generation consoles
might be starting to get left out in the
brain as the ps3 and 360 editions of
mobile combat X have been cancelled like
dying light before it to the last gen
versions of Mortal Kombat X were
originally supposed to come out
alongside the Xbox one ps4 and piece the
editions they then faced two massive
delays before now being cancelled
altogether over the weekend warner
brothers have released a statement that
reads warner brothers interactive
entertainment has come to be regretable
conclusion that we cannot release Mortal
Kombat X for PlayStation 3 and Xbox 360
please know our teams worked diligently
to meet the quality standards set by the
current gen versions of the game we were
not able to get the ps3 and xbox 360
versions to the quality expected of a
Mortal Kombat game and are very sorry
for not being able to deliver the
products as originally planned those who
pre-ordered the game on ps3 or xbox 360
are able to get a refund let me know
down in that comment section if you
think last generation consoles still
have some life left in them for
everything that matters in gaming and be
sure to stay tuned to games but